is it true that you would be interested
in doing a
[Music]
romcom I
mean I want to grab that water right
there it's Manu nalo it's the special
Aquaman bottle beautiful Graphics right
yeah love this I was really happy when
they joined us yeah this is stunning the
Triton yeah drink drink that Manalo get
that get that man
um yeah I mean I want to do everything I
haven't really done like a yeah I
haven't done a romantic comedy I don't
think I've done anything really romantic
I think the closest was Drogo and kisi
and I I don't really want to chalk that
up as a romcom so it ROM yes
C I'm excited I'm actually going to do
my first well I guess I'm going to do
Minecraft with Jack Black who's like a
legend I love him I love him so much
he's amazing and I'm pretty excited I'm
going to do that with him so that'll be
my first like probably big comedy that's
do you like doing comedy do you feel
comfortable doing comedy do you like
exactly the best you were just on it
yeah it's my favorite thing in the world
do you I always find when I go for it
with comedy that I tend to feel a little
sick afterwards like I feel really naked
really vulnerable and really sick to my
stomach and I don't know if it was funny
or not but I know at least I went all
the way you got to go all the way right
you do you do but then I'm like well at
least I'm not going to drive home mad at
myself what was your favorite comedy
that you been in that you loved well I
was thinking particularly 51st days I
know I know
like amazing if you were to do a
romantic comedy is there a
film let's just play a game like is
there a romcom you would ever remake
yeah maybe 50 more
dates you a come back to the islands and
meet a Hawaiian man I would do that of
course are you kidding is there like is
there a woman in history like is there
someone out there you're like you
producing a romcom you're going to do it
would you C who would you ever cast well
aside from the movie we were just
talking about yes exactly oh yeah I'm
just going is my favorite genre and I
think you need to be in it
well there's someone out there really
yeah I don't I don't know if I want to
say it but there's someone out there
okay well that's exciting and I hope it
comes true yeah me too like we would all
be there we really would
[Music]
be